das spiel entwicklungs imperium blizzard
welches megahits wie world of warcraft
diablo und starcraft erschaffen hat er
wirtschaft hätte 2009/10 ganze 1,6
milliarden dollar mit ihren computer
spielen was die wenigsten aber wissen
diese summe erblast verglichen mit den
2,3 milliarden dollar die das
unternehmen durch mobile apps
einkassiert doch auch einzelpersonen
verdienen sich an apps dumm und dämlich
spätestens 2013 seit der vietnamese
domian im alleingang mit dem spiel
flecki birds die welt erobert hatte
sucht jeder nach dem nächsten mega hit
in einem meiner letzten videos habe ich
ohne vorkenntnisse im bereich des
programmierens eine eigene app
entwickelt und zusammen mit eurer hilfe
app store und place tor platz 1 und 2
erreicht mit aktuell über 150000
download in diesem video werde ich
dokumentieren wie ich meine app
vermarkte auch im internationalen raum
in amerika und asien und das dort
natürlich ohne meine reichweite mit
mitteln die jedem zur verfügung stehen
und jetzt das geistig werde zum beispiel
100 euro für facebook werbung ausgeben
die so optimieren dass mir die im
idealfall 200 euro profit bringt und
dann theoretisch einfach 10.000 euro
drauf schmeißen für 20.000 profit wenn
es gut läuft ich werde auch
demonstrieren mit welchen strategien und
tricks die app den spielspaß aufrecht
erhält und die spieler dazu bringt in
app käufe zu tätigen und sogar
freiwillig werbung anzuschauen und zum
schluss werde ich preisgeben wie viel
die app in deutschland aber auch
international erwirtschaftet hat dieses
video wird unterstützt von und ihr
werdet sich glauben vom nanoscale für
die leute angeschrieben dass sie diese
motive so cool finden also den diene und
auf den anderen und deswegen habe ich
gedacht ich drucks einfach auf dem t
shirts oder auf rudis und so weiter und
so fort über den link in den
beschreibungen könnt ihr jetzt abchecken
was ist also für coole sachen gibt das
ganze läuft aber nur eine woche also
wenn ihr bock habt und diese ganze
projekt unterstützen möchte dann wäre
als nur eine woche geht die murger
aktion und auch was durch den merger
eingespielt wird werde ich irgendwann
mal transparent mit euch teilen was
zuvor geschah als name für die app habe
ich mir nach langem überlegen deines
gelb ausgesucht
dieses kleine logo gebastelt der spieler
ist ein zeitreisender mensch der die
dinosaurier vom aussterben retten will
zusammen mit seinem reiz dino versucht
er vom meteoriten lava und tiefen
abgründen zu entkommen
dabei sammelt der dino eier um sich neue
niedliche dinos mit anderen
eigenschaften frei zu schalten wenn
erster diener ist ein stiko saures und
der zweite will denn triceratops das ist
so sicher nicht beschreiben aber ich
hoffe dem ding landleben ein diese
bausteine die ich gewechselt hat kann
man jetzt in sämtliche richtungen
zusammenstössen wenn man jetzt in den
play store geht wenn man jetzt das geld
und kann sich jetzt alle runterladen
seitdem ist einfach so viel passiert
nachdem ich meine app innerhalb von
sieben tagen fertig programmiert hatte
und die einfach schon die app store
charts gestürmt hat und somit mein ziel
komplett erreicht habe habe ich direkt
ein zuschauer von mir aus dem stream
also entwickler bei mir eingestellt der
hat das programmieren übernimmt während
ich mich auf die grafiken und die
konzepte und das level design
konzentrieren
neben der tatsache dass ich jede woche
ein anderes experiment macht und
natürlich nicht jede woche so viel zeit
hatte wie in der woche wo ich das video
zu abgedreht habe liegt mir die app
ultra am herzen und meine
programmierkenntnisse werden dem was ich
vorhabe wie zum beispiel multiplayer
steam version auf gar keinen fall
gerecht ich will dass das spiel spaß
macht euch keinen ärger zu bereits durch
die ganzen bugs und hier kommt lennart
ins spiel ich liebe diesen jungen er ist
ein 18 jähriger schüler und viel mehr im
stream auftritt auf also mir bei
problemen geholfen hat es wäre nicht
live programmiert habe einen tag darauf
habe ich ihn einfach ins boot geholt und
ihn mittlerweile angestellt zu diesem
zeitpunkt hatte die app bereits 75.000
downloads und so viel habe ich bis zu
diesem zeitpunkt mit ihr verdient
0 cent dazu ich weiß in dem video geht
es darum möglichst viel geld zu
verdienen aber ich hab's leben gefunden
wenn wir zuerst zeit dafür verschwendet
hätten die werbung ein zu programmieren
noch bevor das richtige inhalt leben
gibt als die ganzen grundlegenden
funktionen in spielwaren sollte sich das
aber natürlich ändern mir war dabei dann
aber auch wichtig dass die werbung nicht
gezwungen kommt sondern dass der spieler
sich die immer nur freiwillig anschauen
kann und die app nicht einfach das
spielgeschehen unterbricht das wird dann
vielleicht mehr geld einbringen aber das
was ich premium anfühlen ohne
kompromisse es gibt also keine
werbebanner das kind nicht nach jeder
dritten runde irgendeine werbung man
kann sich einfach freiwillig am ende der
runde eine werbung anschauen und dadurch
seine mehr als verdoppeln dadurch
unterstützen die spieler die entwicklung
der app und die werbung unterstützt die
spieler aber die werbung ist nur ein
kleiner teil der einnahmen das meiste
geld wir mit so genannten in-app-käufen
verdient und da gibt es zwei arten den
spielern geld aus den taschen zu leeren
entweder man programmiert das spiel mit
unnötigen wartezeiten und sonstigen
tricks die dafür sorgen dass man geld
ausgeben muss um spaß zu haben oder man
macht er in haft wie zum beispiel vor
neid oder league of legends wo man sich
wenige bis keine spielerischen vorteile
erkaufen kann sondern hauptsächlich
kosmetische gegenstände oder
verkleidungen die das spielgeschehen
nicht beeinflussen und wie vor neid und
co beweisen kann man ja auch auf die
ehrliche art genug verdienen wofür ich
mich dann entschieden da wir sehr wohl
klar nein
ja man kann sich also jetzt im shop der
app für echtes geld die premium währung
werden stein kaufen und wir haben echt
so lange überlegt man den richtigen
namen für die premium währung knochen
juwelen sternenstaub sonstwas bis dann
irgendwann einem screen einfach gesagt
hat bernstein finde aktuell gibt es im
shop zum beispiel für 75 bernstein
dieses pixel gesperrt und für noch mehr
gibt es verschiedene versionen wie zum
beispiel dieses rgb schwert mein
absoluter favorit aber zugegeben auch
das teuerste altem ein ganzes spiel ist
dieses rgb laserschwert alles ist kohle
mit rgb ob das jetzt aber nur ich so
sehe oder ob wir damit riesige einnahmen
machten werden das werden wir bald sehen
positive bewertungen spielen natürlich
mit die größte rolle wenn es darum geht
ob man sich jetzt eine app herunterlädt
oder halt auch nicht deines gelb hat
jetzt im app store schon perfekte 4,7
sterne von 5 und das komplett ohne e
mini tricks aber es gibt auf jeden fall
tricks und die wehr
apps auch eingesetzt vielleicht können
ja dass er sogar ihr werdet von der app
gefragt ob er sie gut findet wenn ihr
auch gedrückt werde direkt zur
bewertungsseite weise geleitet und
können dann eine gute bewertung gelassen
wenn ihr aber auch nein drückt werdet
ihr nicht zur öffentlichen bewertung
hatte weise geleitet sondern höchstens
zu einer e-mail wo ihr dann euer
feedback da lassen könnte das hat dann
nicht öffentlich gepostet wird mit
diesen zwei hunde command gelben werden
kritische meinungen einfach komplett
ausgefüllt hat wie gesagt das geld hat
jetzt schon 4,7 von fünf sternen was
ultras ist also ganz überhaupt nicht
nötig damit die leute meine app
herunterladen müssen sie wissen dass sie
existiert im deutschen raum hilft mir
dann meine reichweite durch youtube
logischerweise enorm für internationale
downloads muss ich mir da aber nennt
besseren trick einfallen lassen und die
promo über verschiedene plattformen
verteilt hier trennt sich das experiment
in zwei sektoren im deutschen raum
erstelle ich natürlich ganz normal von
mir selbst host of instagram stream die
entwicklung auf twitter und macht diese
videos hier aber was wäre jetzt wenn man
gar keine reichweite hätte könnte man
trotzdem eine app erfolgreich
rausbringen das testen wir gezielt im
internationalen raum wo mich auch keiner
kennt mit mitteln die jeder verwenden
kann
diese werbekampagne wenn man so will
sieht so aus um meine app kostenlos
bekannter zu machen erstelle ich
dutzende kleine prägnanter gibbs vor dem
spiel und verteile sie auf reddit in
verschiedenen sabra witz und bezahle
dafür natürlich keinen einzigen cent
diesen trick habe ich in einem video
gefunden ich will das ganze internet
damit zu pflastern und jeden tag mehrere
clips und bilder der app posten die
meisten werden untergehen aber
vielleicht geht eines davon viral um
geld zu verdienen wäre ich auch geld
ausgeben und zwar für werbung ich habe
ein budget für 500 euro gesetzt jeweils
100 euro investiere ich in facebook
werbung im programm werbung in app
werbung youtube werbung und instagram
micro influenza das heißt das ist so was
wie ein placement nur dass diesmal ich
andere leute bezahle
ihr kennt ja bestimmt diese absolut
täglichen abwerbungen wie zum beispiel
nur ein prozent der menschen schaffen
dieses rätsel oder diese werbe clips die
eigentlich absolut gar nichts mit dem
eigentlichen spiel zu tun haben das ding
es der schweiz funktioniert scheinbar
also probiere ich das einfach mal auch
und lassen nicht nur verschiedene
plattformen also in zudem facebook
gegeneinander antreten sondern auch
niveauvolle versus dumme werbung also
werbung wo ich möglichst viel coolen
content zeige dass werbung die
einfach gefühl für dreijährige die
werbung ist als online super simpel
eigentlich so sind sie auch endlich
investiere ich mein geld noch etwas
sinnvolles anstatt deswegen was dummes
zu verzocken 500 euro aufs spiel setzen
tory 260 euro für nur eine woche können
sich irgendwie falsch an die probephase
läuft jetzt für eine woche ich hoffe es
funktioniert nicht verzockt mein geld
nicht hier auch wäre schon cool wenn ich
auch ein paar internationale spieler an
land ziehen können
natürlich direkt goodbye germany gesagt
und bin jetzt einfach hier im paradies
leute ich habe keinen plan ich habe auch
nicht in die zahlenreihen gesehen aber
die app wir wollten ordentlich hessen
kam ein karrieremodus also wenn ich habe
ich jetzt ein echtes problem halte also
um den heißen brei herumzureden die app
hat in deutschland mit in app käufen und
werbung 1700 euro eingenommen
davon waren knapp 500 euro mit in app
käufen und um mir für 1100 euro von
werbung das seht ihr gerade hier im
diagramm im verhältnis zueinander einmal
hier quasi dem hintergrund die nutzer
gewinnen da seht ihr das ist einfach
mega kasper und dann erst später hier
die monetarisierung in orange über
werbung hinzugekommen ist und dann noch
später hier in blau die monetarisierung
über in-app-käufe dazu gekommen ist ist
ganz spannend zu sehen natürlich wenn
jetzt von anfang an schon die werbung
und die innenhöfe dabei gewesen wären
dann wäre natürlich noch mal viel mehr
gewesen zuständig aber um dann erstmal
entfernen vergleich ziehen zu können
betrachte man jetzt mal nur die letzten
sieben tage und schauen ob unsere 500
euro investitionen die wir für die
werbung ausgegeben haben überhaupt
früchte getragen haben
also in deutschland hat die app
innerhalb der letzten sieben tage durch
werbung 91 dollar eingespielt also
ungefähr 83 euro auch in deutschland und
im selben zeitraum hat sie aber 204 euro
durch in-app-käufe angenommen das heißt
durch in der käufe kommt tatsächlich
viel mehr um als mit der werbung aber
wie sieht das jetzt an endlich
international aus hat es jetzt überhaupt
irgend was gebracht dass ich die 500
euro investiert hat habe ich damit jetzt
vielleicht sogar 1000 irgendwo fit
gemacht und kann jetzt einfach geld
rausschmeißen und mich damit um und
dämlich verdienen kurz und knapp nein
ich weiß auch nicht genau woran es lag
aber wir haben 500 euro rausgehauen wir
haben mehrere tausend impressionen
bekommen es als mehrere tausend leute
haben diese werbung gesehen und wir
haben nicht mal zweistellige downloads
bekommt was ich mir absolut gar nicht
erklären kann das ist halt nicht
rentabel ist dass ich nicht wieder fünf
euro reinkriegt war sehr realistisch ist
dachte ich auch nicht dass es klappen
wird aber das ist so wenig damals gibt
schon aus anderen erfahrungen die ich
mit solcher werbung gemacht hab echt
unrealistisch und da ich weiß dass man
so was auf jeden fall erfolgreich machen
kann werde ich da auch wenn wir noch mal
recherchieren und noch mal daran
arbeiten das ist auf jeden fall besser
klappt international haben die also
nicht mal genug messwerte um überhaupt
sagen zu können was da jetzt passiert
ist befinden organisation international
haben also so gut wie gar nichts
gebracht wenn sich so traurig so
negatives ergebnis zu zeigen aber auch
sowas kann natürlich mal passieren die
werbung die wir auf youtube und in
anderen apps gestalten haben die hat
nicht so geklappt wie wir uns erhofft
haben auch die werbung auf integra und
facebook hat nicht wirklich gehabt und
es ist auch viel schwieriger einen
passenden
influenza oder einen micro influenza zu
finden der ein tolles video macht und
auch lust drauf hat als erwartet
andererseits war das was ich auf reddit
gemacht habe komplett ohne zu zahlen
noch am erfolgreichsten
und hat es tatsächlich dafür gesorgt
dass sich einige menschen mit meiner app
auseinandergesetzt haben und auch einige
menschen die app download haben also das
kann ich euch schon mal ist gegeben wenn
ihr kein budget hat dann postet eure
videos oder bilder von eurem spiel auf
jeden fall auf reddit ungefähr 1700 euro
die app jetzt quasi in der zeit
eingespielt das deckt sich ungefähr mit
den ausgaben die ich hatte für den
programmierer für jemanden der mir dabei
hilft die app sind die app stores zu
bringen und die kosten die man natürlich
auch an apple und google zahlen muss um
überhaupt eine app in den app store zu
kriegen und das ist doch schon mal stark
also für die zeit die ich als investor
krieg direkt jetzt kein geld aber das
auch egal ich glaube trotzdem eine
erblichkeit mega boxe ich werde jeden
fall noch einige zeit weiter machen weil
ich wirklich glaube und dann kommt das
dritte video diese reihe und das video
kommt entweder wenn man es geschafft
haben die l prächtig profitabel zu
machen und coole zeit haben wir euch
zeigen können oder wenn die app in ein
paar monaten immer noch kein profit
macht und man vielleicht beschließen
muss mit der entwicklung der app
aufzuhören und ja bis dahin muss ich das
paradies hier wohl verlassen und wieder
zurück nach deutschland
auf geht's in der zukunft haben wir noch
viel mit dem spiel geplant gestern kam
dann ins gelb endlich kostenlos auf
steam online die gesamte entwicklung
könnte unter anderem auf meinem
zweikanalton er verfolgen also abonniert
denen auch mal gerne auftritt könnt ihr
beim fortschritt sogar live dabei sein
und eigene vorschläge einbringen die
premium währung bärenstein aber auch
diese papiertüte hier waren zum beispiel
ideen von zuschauern also schaut auch
gerne mal davor bei die links dazu sind
in der video beschreibung da das projekt
echt komplett aus den fugen gerät haben
wir uns nie es ins boot geholt und der
ist der kurs ab und lennart dem
programmierer also war das buchstäblich
fed hand wirtschaft ihnen links und nils
hilft uns endlich noch mehr dinos und
landschaften zu pixeln damit das spiel
noch viel mehr content bekommt mein
aktueller heißt übrigens 1221 also macht
das nach ja ich bin süchtig nach meiner
eigenen app dass ich irgendwie traurig
den link zum download skate märz findet
ihr ein video beschreibung und auch den
link zur app findet ihr natürlich auch
in der video beschreibung gibt dem ding
mal gerne eine bewertung und schreibt
mir davon hierzu findet und ich geh
jetzt eine runde mit meinem ergebnis wer
zocken
[Musik]